un sixième mandat qui a embrasé le pays
avant même l'annoncé officielle des
résultats
les biélorusses sont descendus dans les
rues de minsk et d'une vingtaine
d'autres du pays pour protester contre
la réélection d'alexandre loukachenko il
n'aurait élections entachées de très
lourds soupçons de fraude dénoncée
notamment par svetlana tirano sky à
principale opposante au président
biélorusse lors de ce scrutin la
candidate malheureuse qui le dimanche
revendiquaient la victoire a pourtant
fini par céder face à de probables
pressions se fait l'âne à tirano sky à 7
ainsi exilé en lituanie d'où elle
appelle toujours à tenir des
rassemblements pacifiques
une fuite qui ne va pas entamé la
détermination des opposants à un sixième
mandat
les manifestations se sont succédé au
fil des jours faisant plusieurs
centaines de blessés et même des morts
ce samedi une foule s'est réunie dans la
capitale autour de la station de métro
pouchkine sky a en hommage à un homme
décédé lors d'une manifestation cinq
jours plus tôt plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont quant à elles
rassemblées autour du funérarium où le
corps était exposé un autre manifestant
a lui aussi trouvé la mort lundi après
avoir été arrêtés la veille dans une
ville du sud du pays et des arrestations
lés forces de l'ordre n'ont réalisé
plusieurs milliers injustement selon de
nombreuses familles qui se sont lancés à
la recherche de leurs proches comme aux
abords de ce centre de détention à minsk
devant lequel plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont pressées ce mercredi
de son côté alexandre lukashenko reste
impassible allant jusqu'à qualifier
mercredi les manifestants de chômeurs et
de criminels à ce moment aussi
ces soi-disant manifestants sont des
gens qui ont un passé criminel mais qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage et se voit
des deux bords ne trouvant pas de
travail alors va te balader dans les
rues et les avenues
c'est pourquoi je demande et je préviens
gentiment tout le monde ceux qui ne
travaillent pas doivent se mettre au
travail la beauté les autorités
biélorusses ont deux
lâché du lest en relâchant plusieurs
milliers de manifestants emprisonnés
la communauté internationale n'a quant à
elle pas tardé à réagir
à commencer par l'union européenne qui
dès le 11 août a remis en doute la
validité du scrutin et appeler les
autorités biélorusses à revoir leur
gestion des manifestations
le harcèlement et la répression
incroyable contre les candidats contre
leur équipe contre les journalistes les
blogueurs les militants les manifestants
pacifiques
même après le vote le niveau de violence
la violence brutale sont inacceptables
nous condamnons cette violence je
demande aux autorités biélorusses de
libérer tous ceux qui sont détenus
illégalement seulement pour des raisons
politiques
bruxelles a finalement donné hier son
feu vert pour l'adoption de nouvelles
sanctions contre minsk nous décision qui
n'a guère plu au président loukachenko
qui a pointé du doigt des interférences
extérieures des interférences également
évoqué à demi-mot par le kremlin qui
dans un communiqué a estimé ce samedi
que la situation était en passe de se
régler
alexandre loukachenko a informé son
homologue russe de la situation en
biélorussie après l'élection
présidentielle
les deux parties ont exprimé leur
conviction que tous les problèmes
actuels seront bientôt résolus
le plus important étant que ces
problèmes ne soit pas exploité par des
forces destructrices qui s'efforce de
nuire à la coopération mutuellement
avantageuse entre les deux pays dans le
cadre de l'union de la russie et de la
biélorussie vladimir poutine aurait
d'ailleurs promis samedi son aide à
alexandre lukashenko pour assurer la
sécurité de la biélorussie à minsk à qui
ses voisins lettons lituaniens et
polonais ont proposé un plan de
médiation pour régler la crise en cours
une offre rejetée par le président henri
[Applaudissements]